mccutchen who is eight for 22 with a
home run in this series he's been good
mccutcheon sends one out to center field
to his former teammate marta going back
to the wall it is gone
a home run for andrew mccutchen what a
way to start this game
you go we go andrew a quick bat that
ball just got out of here in a hurry so
one nothing philly's seven home runs for
koch
second one of the series
here's jazz chisholm jazz two for eleven
in the series
matt joyce with that lead off base hit
leads away from second payoff pitch
and jazz into right center field a base
hit rounding third matt joyce he'll
score jazz chisholm with an rbi single
and the marlins believe it
quality and bad from jazz
laid off a couple of fastballs just
outside the zone this breaking ball
stayed up solid swing and an rbi single
we got a tie ball game and that'll bring
up rafael marshad marshawn will make his
uh
first plate appearance in the big
leagues here
he's a switch-hitting catcher
with a looper out towards center that's
a base hit his first major league hit
with one out here in the top of the
third inning major legs are so easy
[Laughter]
congratulations september 14 2020.
that's awesome
it's one of those old baseball tricks
where you have a worn out baseball in
one hand and you get the real one in the
other and you throw the worn out one
without the hitter realizing here we go
dd
all right first and third here for
aguilar nobody out in the inning aguilar
with the chance to put the marlins on
top long look in finally velasquez
delivers and that is fair down the line
dickerson will score marty on his way to
third he's getting waved around
here comes the throw from dede
not in time a two rbi double for jesus
aguilar the martins take a three to one
lead yeah the big guy does it again
three hits yesterday another big swing
here in game number seven coming through
in the clutch
three consecutive hits here for the
marlins in the inning nissan diaz out of
the game so brian anderson who is
supposed to get the day off will go to
third and everybody shifts over one spot
mickey goes from third to short
and then jazz goes from short to second
take you back to the second isan diaz
going up the first baseline kind of
grimacing most of the way up the line
maybe a little limp toward the end there
i don't think it actually happened in
running i think it happened in his swing
i think so i think it did i think it's
the way he rotated all right let's see
what we got here i thought there was a
little grimace
right there see something went wrong
it's just as he kind of came out of the
box so brian anderson gets the at-bat
here in the fourth inning and a 1-1
pitch from velasquez this one may be
another extra base hit it's going to
roll all the way to the wall miggy row
coming around third he will score and
brian anderson
off the bench gives the marlins a four
to one lead
no off days i didn't sign up for that
now va keeps it going fifth hit against
velasquez fifth extra base hit six
double the season here's scott kingery
his first day back after some time on
the il
out to right field way back goes joyce
turns around and makes the catch he got
his feet in bounds too
that's a touchdown kids
that's what you call a post corner
the best part about it was that he was
slowing down at the end you know right
you got to keep the feet in bounds
don't hit the wall well done made a very
difficult catch look very easy
david phelps is in to the game his 18th
this year facing miguel rojas who puts a
charge into one to left this is
way out of here a home run for miggy
road
they'll have yourself a an afternoon and
early evening miguel rojas connects on
his second homer drives in his eighth
run against the fills this year gene
segura
fly ball out to right
joyce going to try it again
joyce
yeah he did it again
he did it again
it's now officially called the matt
joyce
you got to be kidding me i think he
shocked himself this time there might
have been a little bobble but uh soft
hands right
not over the left shoulder not over the
right shoulder uh yeah wow
and gets the feet down in that's his
second touchdown in the game
i hope you had him on your fantasy team
this weekend right he's piling up the
points he could have joining in facing
marty to lead things off in the seventh
aguilar enjoys to follow
and marte puts a charge into one to
right harper's back goodbye home run
starling marte
to the opposite field yes he's got that
kind of power the other way it might
have been the only question i had about
starlight marty's game my goodness
woodies have not had a hit
since the third inning
haven't had a base runner since that
third inning double by harper yep now
kingly
one two pitch
fly ball right center field well hit
marte going back and it is gone
home run for kingery
second of the year it's a 6-2 ballgame
gone right two batters thus far here in
the ninth two up and two down here's the
two-two pitch swing and a miss strike
three in the ball game
a one two three
top of the ninth and the marlins
complete a wonderful
seven game series against the
philadelphia phillies the marlins are a
game and a half ahead of the fills and
now take aim on the atlanta braves